hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're going to be
going over a nice little strategy and
tactic in the middle game called a decoy
in chess and what it usually entails is
bringing an opponent to a Poisson Square
and forcing them by it usually means of
sacrifice by putting them in a square
where they would not normally want to go
if you look at the situation and it's
blacks move possibly the last move that
you would expect black to make is
bringing his queen to b5 because if he
does that we can bring our Knight to c7
forking this Queen you're not going to
see that move but if you look at a
different position you may see an
opportunity for white to force black to
do that so let's take a look at it let's
give both sides bishops we're going to
go ahead and give white a light square
bishop and black a light square bishop
and if it's White's move if you can see
here we have a decoy and again what
we're going to do is we're going to
sacrifice a piece and force our opponent
to accept that piece and put himself in
the situation they doesn't want to be in
so as we talked about before our dream
scenario would be for this Queen to come
to b5 but how would we do that and we do
that by bringing our LightSquared Bishop
to b5 pinning the the Queen down to the
King now if you look at it before the
black Queen a lot of times will come
here knowing that he can just take this
bishop and he's not protected because
most people when they look at protected
pieces they look at how this piece can
be recaptured right away but if we look
at it if black captures on b5 then now
the knight can come to c7 so although it
wasn't directly defended it is
indirectly defended by the decoy so we
forced them to capture on b5 with their
queen sacrificing our bishop and
in turn we're able to bring our knight
to c7 now we're forking not only the
rook but also the Queen here so this is
an easy way and usually you force the
queen or the king to move to a poison
square in this case we saw the Queen
being forced to move to the poison
square of b5 so we're going to take a
look at a lot of examples of how you can
see and use decoys in your own game one
of the most famous examples of decoy
came from popular game between Petrosian
and pac-man and it's White's move here
as we talked about before we want to get
specific pieces to a poison square but
not always to gain material and that was
the case in this game it was White's
movement he played Queen takes on f6 and
after the black King recaptured on f6
then white brought his Bishop to e5 now
the black King cannot go back to g7 here
and really that move bringing this King
to f6 was really to expose it for a
mating pattern and after the black king
came to g5 the white bishop came to g7
and black resigned in this situation if
you really analyze it it's actually a
mate in 4/4 white and this is what white
was looking at he was not trying to
bring the king to f6 to gain material
quite the opposite he was giving up
material but he knew that if he brought
the King out and exposed him then in
turn he would have a mating pattern so
you always want to be looking for these
things sometimes you may be bringing a
queen or a king to a poison square to
game material like we saw in the last
example or sometimes you want to bring
the King into the center of the game so
you can attack it and win the game so
always be looking for both scenarios if
you're trying to gain material or just
win the game now that we've gone over
what a decoy is in chess it's White's
move here and think about what you think
would be the best move for
and hopefully you came up with Bishop
takes on f7 as you can see here from
this position the only person the only
piece that is defending this Queen on d8
is the king and we can sacrifice our
Bishop and put this King on f7 which is
the poison square black would least
likely to bring his King to f7 but
that's exactly we're going to force him
to do after we take on f7 with our
Bishop he cannot come to d7 because of
our queen and he's forced to take on f7
after so the only defender from the
Queen 98 is gone and now we can take
with our queen on d8 so always be
looking for pieces that you want to
attack or positions that you want to
attack and how you can bring pieces most
notably the queen and the king and bring
those pieces to poison squares so that
you can in turn attack or make the king
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
few more examples let's take a look at
another example this is actually from
another famous game so you may have seen
this exact position before but it's
White's move and think about what you
think would be White's best move
obviously it's a decoy but think about
what you what would be the best decoy in
this situation for white and hopefully
you came up with Queen to d8 the poison
square on this position is d8 and so
we're trying to draw the King to d8 in
this instance were actually not going to
gain any material instead we're going to
win the game even better so after the
King takes on d8 then we can come and
bring our Bishop to g5 and this is a
double check we're attacking with our
bishop and our rook and any time a king
is double checked he has to move his
King he can't move any other piece so
he's forced to move his King he has two
legal moves one is e8 and we can bring
our rook to d8 in his checkmate
or his other
is king to c7 where we can bring our
bishop to d8 and this is checkmate as
well so from this position early on as
you can see we're going to give up an
entire Queen just so that we can get the
King to the poison square of DA so
sometimes you give up in a whole lot of
material just to bring a king or queen
most notably if you're giving up an
entire Queen you're trying to bring the
king to a position but you're really
trying to bring different pieces to
specific squares called poison squares
so that you can gain material or have a
better chance for a win so let's go
ahead and take a look at one more
example for decoy so we can really drive
home the point of what it is and how to
look let's take a look at our last
example of decoy and it's White's move
so take a minute little trickier than
the ones we've seen before but it's
White's move and think about what would
be White's best move in this position
and hopefully you came up with rook to
DA a very creative decoy move as you can
see here the rook can't recapture on da
of the heat can but then we would just
take his Queen on e too and why it's
going to have a very easy game from here
but if you see after rook to d8 if
instead he can't bring his King to g7
because of our rook on the G file but if
he brings his rook or excuse me of his
King to h7 then we can now bring our
rook to g7 attacking this King as you
can see here he would like to recapture
with his knight but we have a pin with
our with our Queen here we're pinning
down the knight to the King and it's
always easy to see a pin on a specific
position it's a little harder to see a
pin to moves down the road but that's
exactly what you need to do sometimes
with the decoy we saw that once we
played rook to d8 that we could pin this
knight down to the King after his only
move his only legal move was to h7 so
it's very important to see this but now
the King takes on g7 again he can't come
to this eighth rank because of our rook
if he doesn't take this rook he's going
to be pretty much in the same trouble he
is if he take
he's going to be mated but if he takes
on g7 then our queen can come down to g2
and there's really nothing that the
black can do to save himself from defeat
he can try to bring his knight into the
action and we can just take you can try
to bring his queen into the action and
we can take you really has no other
options you can never come to this
eighth rank because of our rook and at
the same time we can use our queen and
our pawn here on the h5 we have to we're
going to have it very easy win from here
it's mate in five but depending on what
black does we can have made a little
easier so as you can see here at the
beginning we brought our rook to d8
baiting them asking them to take our
work so we can have a queen but if he
doesn't instead we're going to use a few
additional tactics such as a pin to win
the game very easily so this is how you
can use decoys in your chess game always
be looking for poison squares where you
can draw Queens where you can draw
different kings to and use those
opportunities to not only gain material
but put your opponent in a position
where they don't want to be and you can
win the game easily even if that means
giving up a rook a queen two bishops
whatever it takes to win the game make
sure you go ahead and do that so I hope
you guys enjoy the video on decoy and
chess if you haven't already please
subscribe and make sure you check out
the website the chest website calm and
I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching